Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
full loki episode 5 video there were so many
easter eggs and references we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're doing a
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite easter egg from the episode on the video
there are so many careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet we'll be talking about
everything so everybody hop in the thanos copter
and we'll start at the beginning of the episode
and i'll number all these easter eggs and wtf
moments as we go along just to stay organized
starting with the title the episode was titled
journey into mystery which is a reference to the
marvel comic book journey into mystery where thor
and the loki character debuted for the first time
loki's first appearance was in journey into
mystery number 85 i also think there might be some
clues and foreshadowing in this issue to what's
going on with the real main villain of the series
that i'll talk about when we get to that part
of the episode as you'll notice classic loki is
wearing the same costume because he's meant to be
a version of that original jack kirby looking loki
but the actual episode starts with the camera
rotating around in the tva with the frame upside
down just showing you how things truly have
gone upside down metaphorically since the end
of episode four with the camera pushing through
the wall of the timekeeper's chamber and through
the broken head of that middle timekeeper robot it
continues into the landscape where all the erase
loki's the buildings the vehicles the ships the
other objects go when they get erased by the tva
hunters which they explain is the void you see the
avengers tower actually does not say avengers or
stark industries on it you see kang on it q-e-n-g
which is a reference to the company that's owned
by nathaniel richards aka kang the conqueror so
just yet another king the conqueror easter egg
in the series and if you look at the side of the
bus too there's actually the name of one of the
editors of the series on the side it says callum
ross he just one of the editors for i think it was
episode four or maybe it was episode five a lot of
times when you see people's names on stuff in the
background they're names of people that worked on
the show then we pick up immediately with r loki
in the moments of the post-credits scene where all
the other variant loki's come to tell him we need
to go or you're going to die classic loki tells
him the giant storm which visually kind of looks
a little bit like the black winter is actually
alioth which is a big comic book character that
i'll explain in a second i've already talked
a little bit about all these versions of loki
classic loki played by richard e grant kid loki
played by jack veal who's actually still alive
at the end of the episode as far as we know i'm
hoping they kept him around because they want to
bring him on for young avengers stuff that they're
slowly setting up in the background of the disney
plus series then there's deobia oparei boastful
loki with the hammer and alligator loki there
was a lot of really solid alligator loki moments
he was a champ during this episode we talk about
the superior loki on the series alligator loki
should be the superior loki change my mind the
way they clarify a life is basically this entity
that exists in the void and just eats things
to gain more mass it eats matter and energy so
there's basically no way to kill it and you can't
fight it physically like you would normally fight
a villain that's why they have to enchant it at
the end of the episode a more of a psychic attack
but we'll get to that part in a second there's so
much other stuff to explain alioth has this big
comic book connection to kang so is basically a
temporal being that exists in a limbo state is
the only creature in all of existence that kang
is afraid of that has more time travel powers than
he does during the comics when the avengers were
forced to fight goliath they actually got help
from kang who actually gave them tempus another
immortal time travel being from a limbo dimension
who was able to power himself up enough to fight
alioth into a stalemate for all eternity so even
then the avengers weren't able to kill alioth they
just fought him to a stalemate permanently that
was what boastful loki was referencing when he
called alioth a living tempest comic book tempus
also because ravona renslayer big part of the
episode there was a comic book version of ravona
that accidentally let elias free you notice that
it actually has a face and it seems like a very
wolf-like face i'll talk about that in a second
too because i think the episode is littered
not only with easter eggs that are really cool
but also clues in dialogue that sort of foreshadow
who the real main villain is remember there's only
six episodes they have to wrap this plot up really
fast so i think a lot of the conversations that
people have particularly mobius during the episode
are really important for decoding who's behind
all this but back of the tva sylvie is still busy
fighting ravonna rensslayer who takes her temp ad
and then obviously they go back and forth quite
a bit with ravona trying to stall her long enough
so the tva hunters can show up and using miss
minutes to also help her stall like please pull
up the files on the end of time oh no it's taking
a while taking a while to pull up those files but
the way they explain later in the episode ravona
was not lying when she said she also wanted to
find out who was really behind this but the very
antagonistic way that they're presenting her like
she has that big argument with hunter b15 is
that she doesn't want to burn down the tva she
actually wants to uphold the tv like she wants
to keep its status quo and it sounds like she's
trying to stop sylvie from killing whoever's
behind this like she wants to find them and
warn them as a lot of us suspected she did know
the truth about people getting erased and being
sent to the void the way she explains it is that
she says it's impossible for the tva to completely
erase or reset everything from a branch timeline
so some things from those alternate timelines
get transferred to the void which is where all
the objects and the people come from and as far as
they've thought before the void was supposed to be
the end of all time although that winds up being a
lie too like there is a place that's even further
at the actual end of time which is basically this
rock with the black citadel on it the void is
like the place right before that on the timeline
even though the way ravona explains it they don't
completely understand what's going on with alioth
they just know that things don't come back but
that's the whole idea whoever's behind the tva
created alioth to get rid of all that stuff to
basically be the trash compactor for the void
which is where all the trash they couldn't delete
wound up going and the reason they explained there
are so many loki's that are alive here like all
these other many versions of loki is because they
survive whereas other regular people do not
like you see the ship in the uss eldridge all
those sailors they get eaten in like two seconds
when elias shows up so just to be clear ravona
knows about the secret of the void but she does
not know who's really behind this inside that
citadel at the actual end of time and she didn't
know about the actual end of time either but all
this talk about the end of time just made me think
of doctor who the end of time with david tennant
ravona also explains that the official dogma that
was passed down which they now know as a lie was
that the timekeepers were transforming the void at
the end of time into a utopia although all that's
out the window but like i said even though ravona
knows about the lie now she doesn't want to burn
the tba down like everyone else like no we have
to we have to keep this going it's important like
she has completely drunk the kool-aid and this is
meant to be an origin story for her just like it
is for some of these other characters like sylvie
for instance so i think this is setting her up for
a really big villain arc in the mcu in the future
she has so many deep ties to kane the conqueror we
know that he's going to be the main antagonist of
ant-man 3 so i think that's just sort of putting
her on a collision course for that character
eventually if she doesn't already have some
association with him that we don't know about back
in the void we meet back up with a team of loki's
that are leading our loki across the landscape
you also see an old sailing ship i believe this is
supposed to be a big easter egg but i'm not sure
which sailing ship this is meant to be next to the
very star trek enterprise looking spaceship saucer
section here just meant to highlight how the void
is a dumping ground for all points in the timeline
past present and future at pretty much every point
in the episode anytime they're outside in the
camera pans around the landscape it's littered
with easter eggs in the background i'm sure you
could zoom in enhance for days on all this footage
and find more stuff in the distant background they
walk amongst the ruins of a bunch of large statues
you can't really see what the heads are for these
statues all these rare birds that are running
around seem very familiar but i can't place them
specifically so if you think you know what these
birds are meant to be just write it below in the
comments kid loki pulls his sword on r loki to get
him to shut up and his sword is actually a really
big deep cut from the comics too because he winds
up giving it to loki later the flaming sword
i believe it's pronounced levitine it's loki's
ancestral blade which he's capable of summoning
using his powers the same way that thor summons
mjolnir it appeared in the comics for the first
time in thor number 368 just a couple months after
frog thor appeared for the first time which was
365. we see frog thor a little bit later in the
episode so i'll point him out in a second he was
one of the cooler easter eggs in the episode but
now loki has his ancestral blade remember they're
all loki's so if it's kid loki's ancestral blade
technically it's also r loki's ancestral blade
but in the old norse language levitine just means
damaged twig you could think of that as a metaphor
for the loki character because classic loki talks
about how they're all fundamentally damaged in any
time they try to fix themselves the tva stops them
arrests them and tries to erase them sends them to
the void you also notice kid loki's got a toaster
in his backpack there but you have to remember
that they've been scavenging things for their
special bunker that's where all their cool stuff
comes from are loki asked them some of the early
standard questions too so they get past some of
the logic like why can't we just create another
nexus event because the tva apparently does not
care at all what happens in the void then kid
loki claims that his nexus event that got him
pruned was actually killing his version of thor
which might be a comic book easter egg for kid
loki in the comics when he was starting to piss
thor off thor strung him up by his neck and dared
him to kill him so in the comics he did not do
that because kid loki was kind of a good version
of loki but i guess that they're saying that this
version of kid loki did wind up killing his thor
when faced with a similar situation then they walk
past the thanos copter one of the greatest easter
eggs from the episode it even says thanos on the
tail of the helicopter also if you look here
you can see a giant version of yellow jacket's
helmet from the first ant-man movie you kind of
wonder what he did to get him sent here they also
walk by what seems like an undetonated nuclear
bomb marking the entrance to their underground
shelter you also notice later in the episode when
they open the hatch the runes on top seem like the
loki sigil with some asgardian writing on it it
might just be enchantments to help protect the
place but then as they travel down through the
many layers of dirt like the camera pans down so
you see what's buried in the dirt and there's
all kinds of easter eggs what seems like an
infinite amount of lunch trays for some reason
you see a whole version of mjolnir just waiting
for one of these loki's to become worthy and call
it then there's a jar with frog thor in it in his
costume banging on it trying to get out kind of
screaming in frustration with t365 on it that's
a reference to the issue where he debuted thor
number 365. like i said a couple issues before
they debuted loki's ancestral blade that he gets
at the end of the episode maybe if he's lucky frog
thor will be able to use that version of mjolnir
to escape if he's still worthy but when they enter
the actual shelter it looks like the ruins of
an old bowling alley with just a whole bunch of
junk that they've collected boastful loki taunts
r loki asking him if he left his glorious purpose
back at the tva and when loki says something like
that he's referencing sylvie we get a better look
at kid loki's throne and boastful loki actually
explains that kid loki is technically the boss of
the loki's in their little faction here they have
a polybius arcade machine which is a big urban
legend i've already explained that in a couple of
my videos is a really cool detail in the episode
there's all kinds of other odd junk but they also
have a williams space mission pinball machine
from 1976 in kid loki's throne actually looks like
it's repurposed from an old santa claus christmas
throne because of all the candy canes in the
santa that's sitting next to it it does look like
something that a little kid would pick as a throne
the back of the tva rivona tells this big lie
about a prototype void ship designed to withstand
temporal forces at the end of time i don't know if
this is meant to be an easter egg for something
from the comics it could be reference to that
but the whole idea was that she was just stalling
for time so the hunters could show up so a lot of
what she was saying was meant to be lies but they
do try to call up the files that loki was trying
to access back during episode two the librarian
told him those are off limits like he wanted to
know about the beginning of time the creation of
the tva he wanted to know about the end of time
but she wouldn't give him any of that later in
the episode ravona does get miss minutes to start
looking up those files so they actually do have
them ravona also makes a wizard of oz reference
saying that they're going to find the man behind
the curtain i've been talking about that the last
couple of episodes just because the way they've
been playing a lot of the series setting up these
big fake outs and twists it seems like it'll be a
very wizard of oz style reveal there are a couple
other big clues during the episode i think that
helped foreshadow who that person is going to be
after they reveal the double cross and she says
that she'll put sylvie in a time loop prison if
she gives up the special red portals that loki
got dumped in during episode four the one good
memory that sylvie says she has sounds like it's
meant to be when she was with loki and they were
falling in love on lament one just based on the
way the producers and the writers talk about the
relationship arc that they have during the series
but as a lot of people guessed she actually does
wind up using a wand to zap herself into the
void the prevailing theory was that she would let
herself get pruned somehow so that she would just
automatically go to the void where loki got sent
we go back to the bunker and they start panning
around as all the loki's are just chilling out
having some of that roxanne bran box wine i'm sure
it tastes terrible but apparently alligator loki
really loves it boastful loki true to his name
boasts that he defeated iron man captain america
and collected all six infinity stones like he's
saying during his version of avengers infinity war
in avengers endgame he defeated all the avengers
and took all the infinity stones but then all the
other loki's called bullcrap on him i love how
alligator loki is the first one to call him out
to which he responds saying the alligator loki's
nexus event was eating the wrong neighbor's cat
who proceeds to jump out and bite the hell out of
him just foreshadowing him biting off president
loki's hand also foreshadowing the big battle
royale between all the loki's later in the episode
just the idea that all of these loki's are never
going to all get along with each other because
they're such narcissists then classic loki
explains his backstory saying that everything
up to the events of avengers infinity war was
the exact same for him mostly but instead of
sacrificing himself like our original loki did
he says that he just cast a perfect illusion
fooling thanos into thinking he snapped his
neck then hid from everyone including thor
and just kind of floated off into space by
himself until he could go quietly retire
on a planet remotely where nobody would find
him the way he explains it though he was
basically running away from his pain like he said
everywhere i went i only found pain so i tried
to find somewhere where that wouldn't happen so
he was basically running away from his problems
which is a big call to action for r loki sort of
setting up his hero arc by the end of the episode
where he sort of stands his ground with sylvie
also with a little help from a redeemed classic
loki who himself gets a pep talk from mobius but
the way he explains it classic loki says that he
got arrested by the tva because he eventually got
lonely eventually in his old age and wanted to see
thor again wanted to see everyone else he knew
and as he stepped off the planet the tva showed
up immediately to prune him but classic loki's
story is also some foreshadowing i think for
our loki's arc and for what's going on with the
villain of the series so the head writer michael
waldron talked about this guiding principle for
loki's character the reason why he does everything
all this mischief all these bad things that he
does is because he's terrified of being alone
that was also what he was talking about during
episode four when he was trying to get sift to
stop kicking him in the nuts during the time
loot prison it wasn't a lie he was telling the
truth about that they make a whole bunch of jokes
about daggers saying that they're super cool but
then classic loki sort of sets up his big illusion
at the end of the episode claiming that they hurt
their abilities as loki's to develop more
powerful magic which i think also plays into
the idea of loki using the enchantment abilities
that sylvie has at the end of the episode too like
you can do this too because you're loki just
like me like loki realizes oh we're capable of
being more powerful than people think that we
are classic loki also jokes that it would be
terrifying to meet a female version of themselves
just referencing sylvie then as arloki opens the
hatch to leave he's faced with president loki in
all the other loki's that are part of his faction
i've already done a video about some of these
other versions of loki but they're basically just
meant to be wildly different marauders like later
in the episode there's a reference to different
bands that you run into in the void like well
either their cannibals their marauders or their
marauding cannibals this faction of loki's led
by president loki just seems more like marauders
but then we jump to sylvie on an old bus in the
void in the ruins of a bunch of old classic cars
all over the place alioth consumes the bus just
as she escapes then as sylvie tries to enchant
alioth she actually gets a vision of what lies
beyond the void giving her the idea for the end of
the episode she sees the citadel the door that we
saw from the earlier trailers she sees that it's
sitting on an asteroid next to the sacred timeline
we've seen that in all the earlier trailers but
they hid the citadel on top of the rock we just
saw the rock itself in the sacred timeline but she
also sees this vision of a glowing bright light
at the top of this tower which seems like it's the
source of the power that's behind everything that
whoever's behind this is using i also think it's
a callback to the depiction of loki on the issue
where he debuted for the first time standing on
top of that tower shouting down at thor trying to
prove that he's more powerful but then confirming
all our theories just as she's about to be
consumed completely moebius drives up to save her
in a skinny pizza delivery car then as they drive
away in the landscape you can see the sphinx you
can see the great pyramid of egypt on one side
then off in the distance over here on the right
i believe this is meant to be the greek acropolis
like i said everywhere in every direction all over
the landscape easter eggs everywhere as far as
the eye can see then they confirm that president
loki's group is a totally different enemy faction
of loki's inside the void they say they prefer to
be thought of as snakes instead of wolves that's
meant to be a callback to the wolf's ears wolf's
teeth are near the asgardians sang from earlier
in the series also the snakes is a reference to
loki turning himself into a snake like in thor's
story from thor ragnarok when they were children
you could also think of it as a reference to the
midgard serpent you know giant snake which in
norse mythology is loki's middle child you could
also think as the wolf reference as being a call
back to fenris wolf or fenrir wolf in norse
mythology which is also one of loki's children
young sylvie's toys the little toy of the wolf was
also meant to be a reference to that they have a
big joke about loki's betraying each other right
and left because just betrayal is a big trope
of loki's stories with boastful loki claiming
that he betrayed kid loki in order to take his
santa throne for himself but after which president
loki then double crosses boastful loki starting
their big brawl alligator loki bites his hand off
which is hilarious like i said alligator loki is
the superior loki you see our loki kind of trying
to dodge everything and just throw his hands up
in disgust like i can't believe these people boss
tier move kid loki just throws alligator loki at
one of the other loki's but then sort of setting
up the big twist at the end of the episode classic
loki creates a perfect illusion to distract
president loki's men while they use one of the
portals to escape to the surface then as they're
walking away behind them you see the ruins of
some massive spaceship behind them it's not clear
which spaceship this is so if you think you know
what this is a reference to just write it below in
the comments then everyone heads for a life at the
same time they all sort of converge on the same
place kid loki whips out a rift detector that he
used for detecting when stuff winds up coming into
the void when alternate timelines get dumped here
that leads them to the uss eldridge so i've
already explained this before but the uss eldridge
was a real-life u.s navy ship that they were using
to test cloaking technology like star trek klingon
cloaking technology completely vanish it from
human view and radar detection for a short period
in the urban legend goes that they were successful
but it disappeared briefly amidst this green smoke
and sailors got fused to the bulkhead there were
all kinds of theories about it not disappearing it
actually traveling through time so this is them
just sort of playing on that idea but they use
the eldritch to remind you why you can't fight
it physically because they use all their giant
guns on the ship to try and fire at it and because
goliath absorbs all matter and energy it just eats
all the stuff that they fire at it just setting
up the concept that they have to take silvie's
approach of a psychic attack enchanting it they
also show you what it looks like when alive eats
something and he basically picks the ship dry like
eating chicken off the bone leaving nothing but
the bits of the framework back in the tva ravona
rensslayer sort of sets up more of her villain arc
against loki and sylvie at the end of the series
like she's trying to also get to this place at
the end of time she'll probably successfully get
there as well in the finale at some point but not
to stop whoever's behind this but to prevent
sylvie and loki from killing them then there's
this really interesting conversation that mobius
has with classic loki that i think helps also
foreshadow what's really going on with the main
villain of the series so they just start with
this funny argument about whether or not alligator
loki is really a loki mobius claims that he has no
memory of the tva ever arresting in alligator loki
he says maybe he could just be pulling a long con
but that would make him even more of a loki and
they say when it comes to loki's there's always
a game within the game which i think is a big
clue also to what's happening with the person
in the citadel at the end of time beyond alioth
the game within the game because it's almost
like loki and sylvie travel into alioth through
this portal to get to the citadel like the game
literally and metaphorically inside the game of
the void like goliath was the guard dog protecting
the entrance to the actual end of time and because
it kind of looks like a wolf it makes you think of
fenris wolf so if as mobius says it's always a
loki pulling along khan games within games all
these themes of loki's betraying other loki's
earlier in the episode then shouldn't whoever's
behind all this tv nonsense be yet another loki
you know play the akatha all along theme music
it was loki all along also you think about classic
loki's story about going to live by himself
on this remote planet and you think about this
asteroid where the citadel is is basically a
rock by itself at the end of time there's nothing
else that's here so it just seems like a lot of
the dialogue a lot of the conversations the easter
eggs are pointing towards it being some sort of
loki that's behind all of this then when
mobius talks about setting things right in
the tva everyone's telling the truth if he makes
it back it never being too late to change that's
what inspires classic loki to sacrifice himself
to help sylvie and loki enchant alioth then when
loki and sylvie are talking having their little
conversation sort of coming to terms with their
relationship she jokes about the costumes being
really uncomfortable that's actually meant to be
a real life joke about the actors having to wear
really uncomfortable costumes when they're filming
if you've ever watched paul bettany take off his
vision costume in real life it is crazy how much
time he has to spend in the makeup chair just to
get that on then loki says he won't betray sylvie
just because that's not who he is anymore they
make it sound like they're gonna really go for
a relationship if they're successful in defeating
whoever's behind all this like if they survive the
finale then they'll try to make a go of it then
when they move to the wide shot of the landscape
off in the background on the left here you can see
the wreckage of the dark aster which is ronin ship
from the first guardians of the galaxy movie they
give mobius the 10 pad so that he can return to
the tva and as he says big call back to the first
episode burn it to the ground like loki foretold
i'm gonna burn this place to the ground
then kid loki gives his flaming sword his
ancestral blade to our loki like i said it's a
version of his ancestral blade from the comics
then when loki and sylvie move to try and stop
goliath start distracting him stalling for time
and they start painting across the landscape yet
more easter eggs you notice this statue here with
three heads is actually a representation of the
three-sided head of the living tribunal so it's
a statue of the living tribunal but it's not the
first time that they've referenced it in the mcu
that was the doctor strange movie with the staff
of the living tribunal and there was supposed to
be an avengers infinity war deleted scene during
the titan fight where doctor strange would have
taken thanos to be judged by the living tribunal
they wound up getting rid of it just because
it got way too complicated and it was another
character that they would have had to explain
so hopefully at some point in a future movie
we'll see the actual living tribunal show up
then when classic loki turns around here you
notice behind him in the background you can
see the ruins of a shield helicarrier i do wonder
who all these giant skeletons belong to they're
littered across the landscape when loki and sylvie
are stalling for time behind them this just seems
like the ruins of an oil drilling rig and then it
winds up taking classic loki creating a perfect
illusion of the entire city of asgard palace
and all right down to the trees in the streets
in order to distract goliath his hero music
also sounds like a mixture of the classic thor
theme from the marvel movies mixed with a little
bit of the main loki series theme music you also
notice that his version of asgard looks a little
bit different from our main version of asgard i
think just because he's classic jack kirby looking
loki like he's recreating a version of his version
of asgard he winds up going out like a boss
sacrificing himself screaming glorious purpose
i absolutely love richard e grant's performance
in the episode as this character he was fantastic
hopefully someday they'll be able to bring him
back and because there's a multiverse there's an
infinite number of loki's that you can bring back
then silvie convinces r loki that he is able to
use enchantment abilities because they're the same
they're both loki's in the whole idea though you
have to remember sylvie kind of explained how
enchantment works or at least how her version
of enchantment works is that she has to grab on to
a memory of whatever it is that she's enchanting
so they're basically grabbing on to the memory of
this black citadel on the rock at the end of time
and they're just using it to pacify alive in
the way they're presenting this he was just
sort of like the guard dog that was guarding
the gateway like a portal to the actual end
of time we see a much larger version of the
citadel that sylvie saw in her vision earlier
beyond it in the background the white that you
see arcing across the frame that's meant to be
a representation of the sacred timeline from
all the trailers like this white energy beam
extending across space and where all these
colors sort of meet you're looking at the
actual vanishing point of the multiverse like
all timelines converging at the vanishing point
then the only big difference they make with
the credits here is that you actually see
all the major loki variants from the episode all
the ones that had speaking lines at least added
to these special shots like someone was taking
pictures of them but i think what they're going
for here is basically they're going to combine
the concepts of he who remains in the comics who's
like the last living being left in the multiverse
who created the time keepers but in the comics
it's an actual person and they'll just combine
that concept with possibly another loki like
yet another loki but let me know in the comments
just based on all the evidence that you've seen
who do you actually think the real main villain
is who's going to be he who remains who created
the tva in this entire thing my full loki episode
6 finale video will post next wednesday just like
normal i have a couple big bonus videos that i'm
working on that i'll post before then if you have
any big requests or big questions or videos that
you want me to do based on this episode too just
let me know in the comments i've got a new finale
video that i'll post tomorrow while you wait for
that click here for all my loki episode videos
and click here for my spider-man no way home first
look video for all of his brand new spider-man
suits in the movie there are a bunch of them
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!